[Música]
amnistía internacional pidió a los
gobiernos de Perú y chile que
desmilitarizan las fronteras cuando
decenas de familias migrantes permanecen
varadas en la zona limítrofe entre ambas
naciones lima y Santiago indicaron que
trabajan en Establecer un corredor
humanitario para enfrentar la situación
tenemos análisis
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva afirmó decretos que demarcan
seis nuevos territorios para pueblos
indígenas la medida garantiza el uso
exclusivo de los recursos naturales en
esas tierras expertos aseguran que esta
medida permitirá además controlarla
deforestación en la amazonía
Paraguay votará este domingo 30 de abril
para elegir al nuevo presidente y para
renovar la composición de la cámara de
diputados y del senado a pesar de ser el
país que más crece en la región arrastra
algunos problemas estructurales como
pobreza y baja atención médica que
deberá manejar el nuevo presidente
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos con la tensión
en la frontera y también en la
diplomacia entre Perú y chile esto a
raíz de la reciente crisis migratoria en
la zona limítrofe entre ambos países
donde cientos de migrantes permanecen
varados intentando cruzar a Perú para
continuar con el retorno a sus países de
origen desde chile El Ejecutivo peruano
envió militares a la zona fronteriza
para que apoyen las labores de la
policía que se mantendrá en primera
línea lima y Santiago intentan
establecer ahora un corredor humanitario
que alivia la emergencia entre tanto
amnistía internacional pidió a los dos
gobiernos desmilitarizar sus fronteras y
los acusó de impulsar políticas crueles
para las decenas de familias que
permanecen varadas anteriormente
hablamos con Ana piquer abogada y
directora adjunta de investigación para
las Américas de amnistía internacional
que nos contaba si solucionan algo un
corredor humanitario o es simplemente un
parche para la crisis
puede llegar a ser un parche va a
depender un poco también de cómo
simplemente y para qué se implemente
pero como bien dices personas
venezolanas y haitianas
pues para ellos pueden no ser una opción
al volver a sus países son países que
están en tremendas crisis humanitarias y
Derechos Humanos que no les ofrecen un
espacio seguro que ellos llegaron a a
Chile a Perú o a muchos otros países en
busca de un lugar seguro donde vivir y
lo que están encontrando es
discriminaciones estigmatizaciones
criminalización y además estas
respuestas individuales de cada uno de
los estados que En definitiva van
generando un efecto dominó en que estas
personas no literalmente no tienen un
lugar donde estar Y eso es lo lo que es
desgarrador y lo que es también un
incumplimiento por parte de las
obligaciones en materia de derechos
humanos y de derecho internacional de
los refugiados por parte de cada uno de
los países de supuesta acogida
el presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio
Lula Silva reconoció seis nuevos
territorios indígenas reactivando el
compromiso Estatal con los pueblos
nativos los cuales sufrieron retrocesos
durante el gobierno de Jair bolsonaro
durante la semana cientos de miembros de
las comunidades avanzaron sobre las
calles de Brasilia denunciando
violaciones de la industria minera y
forestal en sus territorios Ramiro cueva
verena nos cuenta más
Brasil ha retomado el reconocimiento de
los territorios indígenas y demarcó seis
más en los estados de acre halagoas
amazonas
ciara goiás y Río Grande de un sul así
lo anunció el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva en un acto junto a grupos
indígenas en el campamento Tierra Libre
y reafirmó su compromiso con Los nativos
brasileños
[Aplausos]
no quiero que ninguna tierra indígena
quede sin demarcar durante mi mandato
es un compromiso que asumí y un
compromiso con ustedes desde la campaña
no podemos permitir que vuelva a pasar
lo que pasó en las tierras llanomami en
el estado de roraima esto no puede
volver a pasarle a ningún pueblo
indígena
el gobierno del izquierdista reanudó los
procesos establecidos por la ley que fue
paralizada durante el mandato de Jair
bolsonaro los indígenas han denunciado
la violación de las tierras por parte de
empresas mineras y madereras Lula
repitió el objetivo de deforestación 0 y
dijo que necesitará a los nativos como
Guardianes de la selva tras el anuncio
del presidente los miembros de la
comunidad se mostraron esperanzados de
cara al futuro
en nuestra región tenemos un área que
necesita ser demarcada y ratificada como
muchas otras áreas en Brasil en este
caso vinimos aquí para reforzar que
estas luchas de fundamental porque sin
tierras indígenas no hay vida Nuestro
principal objetivo en este momento es la
demarcación de tierras
esta nueva medida se opone a los deseos
del gobernador de Amazonas Wilton Lima
quien sostiene que esas tierras solo
pueden mantenerse bajo una lógica
financiera
oportunidad si no das oportunidades a
las personas que viven en la selva no
dudes de que utilizarán los recursos del
Bosque para garantizar el sustento de
sus familias así que no se puede hablar
de preservación del medio ambiente con
pobreza sus familias con el nuevo
decreto de Lula más de 550.000 hectáreas
de tierra serán protegidas y se sumarán
a unas 600 reservas indígenas que ya
estaban reconocidas por el estado una
superficie equivalente al 14% del
territorio nacional
nos vamos hasta Uruguay y en donde el
senado aprobó la reforma pensional que
sube la edad de jubilación de los 60 a
los 65 años impulsada por el presidente
Luis lacalle Pou será un aumento
paulatino que pese a ser aprobado ha
sido criticado por los propios socios de
gobierno de la calle Pou y por la
oposición de izquierdas del frente
amplio así como por los sindicatos el
gobierno argumenta que la población está
envejeciendo y que el sistema no se
sostiene pero la oposición contrapone
otras formas de financiación
y el próximo 30 de abril Paraguay va a
las urnas para elegir al nuevo
presidente y renovar así la composición
de la cámara de diputados y del senado a
pesar de ser el país que más crece en la
región arrastra algunos problemas
estructurales un tercio de la población
vive en condición de pobreza y la
atención médica para la población es
escasa el nuevo presidente de este país
de 7 millones y medio de habitantes
tendrá que manejar estos desafíos el
siguiente informe es de Valeria sakoney
y a mingidara
[Música]
Así se ve desde el aire el barrio de
bañados en Asunción aquí unas 100.000
personas viven en condiciones precarias
entre calles de tierra batida que se
convierten en charcos cada vez que
llueve
zanahoria Gloria es una líder
comunitaria premiada por el proyecto de
las Ollas populares una iniciativa
solidaria que inició durante la pandemia
para mitigar el hambre entre sus vecinos
es un barrio Que prácticamente no tiene
nada no tenemos educación digna no
tenemos un techo digno no tenemos
alimentación los bañados surgieron hace
70 años por los flujos migratorios desde
las áreas Rurales millares de campesinos
fueron expulsados del campo primero por
caudillos locales y después por la
mecanización del cultivo de la soja este
es una calle transitada y mira Cómo está
Solamente insistimos en época
electorales unos dos millones de
paraguayos tienen ingresos inferiores al
costo de una canasta básica el 4% de la
población vive en condiciones de pobreza
extrema
buenas Buen día desde hace 10 años
Arturo atiende a los casi 5.000
pacientes de la chacarita otro barrio
humilde de la capital paraguaya falta de
medios los asaltos y las malas
condiciones laborales marcan el día a
día de estos profesionales durante la
campaña electoral ha surgido la
propuesta de la privatización del
sistema sanitario algo que estos médicos
rechazan se dice haz un mayor control de
los recursos una mejor asignación yo
creo que sí fue el estado puede seguir
funcionando como administrador y rector
de la salud pública en nuestro país
pobreza y salud dos de los principales
retos para quien aspiran al cargo de
presidente de Paraguay para los próximos
cinco años
nos vamos hasta la Habana la capital de
Cuba a donde llevó la delegación
negociadora de la guerrilla colombiana
del ejército de liberación nacional el
eln allí comenzará la semana entrante la
tercera ronda en los diálogos de paz con
el gobierno colombiano el Habana está ya
también la delegación gubernamental este
tercer ciclo se ha [__] por
diferencias en las negociaciones y por
las acciones violentas de la guerrilla
que en marzo dejaron 10 militares
muertos en un ataque en la región
colombiana del catatumbo por las
delegaciones del gobierno cerramos con
imágenes de una cena poco común en el
barrio de Williamsburg de Nueva York uno
de los barrios de moda de la urbe en
Rosa un espacio para eventos de este
lugar de Nueva York 40 personas se
presentaron para realizar ejercicios de
respiración y una cena vegana totalmente
desnudos Charlie and Max la creadora del
evento aseguró que con la experiencia
Busca Conectar a los comensales con su
ser más puro y auténtico una experiencia
por la que cada comensal paga entre 40 y
4 y 88 dólares
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]